[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce big red paix dont
l'invité guillaume cairou qui est le
nouveau et jeune président de la chambre
de commerce des yvelines commerce et
d'industrie d'assez si des yvelines vous
avez été élu à l'unanimité il faut dès
que votre votre liste a remporté tous
les sièges c'est ça oui dès que
les entreprises chinoises qui sont au
nombre de 1 peu plus de 100000 ont
massivement voté puisqu'on est l'une des
territoires de la région qui s'est le
plus mobilisés sur le terrain en termes
de nombre d'électeurs ce qui est assez
cette formule alors on va commencer par
des questions peut-être un peu basique
pour comprendre quel est votre rôle est
votre votre mission et qu'est ce que
c'est une chambre de commerce et
d'industrie déjà déjà c'est ce que je
viens de dire c'est c'est avant tout
c'est l'assemblée de l'ensemble des
entrepreneurs et commerçants du
territoire donc qui représente les 106
mille les 106 1000 entreprises et
agences du territoire
et derrière en fait cette cellule le
porte-parole finalement de tous ces
entrepreneurs qui va devoir mettre en
place en fait de la politique économique
pour nos entreprises sur le territoire
est là pour les cinq prochaines années
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
alors on va parler de votre parcours
après qui est un parcours très
intéressant parce qu'il est à la fois
atypique et plein de motivation mais
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
présider cette instance avant d'avoir eu
envie de présider une chambre de
commerce parce que c'est pas quelque
chose dont on rêve c'est pas c'est pas
un rêve d'enfant
c'est un cheminement en fait c'est un
cheminement c'est un parcours de vie
parce que j'ai d'abord été éducateur de
rue j'ai été enseignant en physique
chimie dans le secondaire et puis j'ai
travaillé dans différentes entreprises à
différents postes et puis un jour au
chômage j'ai créé mon entreprise
puis et puis quand vous créez une
entreprise vous êtes un acteur de la
cité vous êtes un acteur vous êtes un
acteur économique vous puis vous engager
dans la vie dans la vie de tous les
jours et c'est un peu ce cheminement la
d'engagement de cet engagement au niveau
des travailleurs indépendants que j'ai
que j'ai soutenu au travers les
organisations professionnelles et
patronales comme le medef par exemple
qu'ils représentent
mais vous appartenez au modef vol et
donc l'idée voilà c'est ça chemine an
après 2,2 de faire un peu plus de que de
représenter les entreprises de d'agir
pour ces entreprises est dans une
période un peu particulière et et voilà
on m'a poussé quelque part à
prendre ses responsabilités
cindy histoire dans les chambres de
commerce ça commence dans les années 60
la dernière réforme je crois que cette
donc c'est quelque chose qui est très
ancrée dans dans les territoires il ya
des fonctionnements différents dans
l'île de france sur les départements
ailleurs ce sont plutôt les régions 1
c'est ça et au mieux vous êtes lié aux
autres joueurs de commerce il va en fait
c'est un c'est un réseau en fait c'est
un réseau de l'ensemble des chambres
consulaires il n'a je crois à peu près
130 en france
et on fonctionne effectivement par
région on est rattachée aujourd'hui à la
région
paris ile de france qui est l'une des
premières régions économiques avec un
peu plus d'un million d'entreprises
c'est la première chambre de commerce au
monde comme vous le disiez c'est une
vieille dame les chambres de commerce et
d'industrie en près de cinq cents ans la
première a été créée la première été
créée à marseille où dit aussi
chambon organisations consulaires
puisque les premiers élus de ces
chambres de cause de deux commerces
étaient des consuls
et puis voilà il ya il ya une
transformation aujourd'hui qu'on subit
de plein fouet alors on parle beaucoup
de cette transition écologique numérique
climatique énergétique est globalement
social que nous sommes en train de vivre
et ses chambres de commerce et
d'industrie dans les territoires doivent
se réinventer et donner un nouvel élan
aux politiques économiques et sociales
du département des territoires on va
parler de sa vie juste un mot qui
finance les cci alors que vous avez des
subventions l'état est quand même l'un
des principaux financeurs des chambres
de commerce et d'industrie et puis les
entreprises à travers ce qu'on appelait
la tfc la traque de la taxe sur les
frais de chambres qui aujourd'hui
s'appelle la taxe cécité cci qui
globalement c'est vrai que c'est pas une
c'est pas énorme taxe les x lion de
l'entreprise ça donne quand même un
petit peu de latitude et cet axe a au
fil des réformes successives a fondu
comme neige au soleil maintenant
effectivement il faut réinventer aussi
de nouveaux modes de financement et de
nouveaux modes de travail avec les
acteurs que sont les collectivités les
départements et les régions et c'est cet
ensemble avec l'état qui finance le
développement économique des territoires
donc il ya une grosse capacité de
financement si on prend en compte
l'ensemble de ses acteurs alors parliez
justement des rapports avec les chefs
d'entreprise vous dites il faut que les
cci soit plus visible pour les chefs
d'entreprise vous allez danser y avait
des guildes et gilet jaune vous dansez
voulait gilet bleu c'est ça c'est ça
l'idée en fait pourtant mais l'idée
terrifie nativement secteur au cours de
la campagne
souvent les commerçants et les
entrepreneurs sur les marchés dans dans
l'est dans les zones d'activités dans
les zones industrielles nous on dit mais
finalement la cci est pas très visible
on ne sait pas trop ce que ce que vous
faites il ya un axe dont j'ai pas parlé
il ya effectivement ce soutien aux
entreprises et quand même l'une des
premières missions qu'elle deuxième axe
qui est plus visible mais finalement pas
visible par les entreprises en tant que
tel ce sont l'ensemble des écoles des
cfa que la cci que les cci gère en ile
de france
c'est plus de 70 mille jeunes qui sont
formés chaque année à travers 24 campus
des écoles très connues telles que hec
escp
laissiez pour les ingénieurs
informatiques
c'est randy dans le domaine de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration les
gobelins dans le domaine de l'image et
du motion design bref on a vraiment
cette capacité mais d'un autre côté
c'est vrai que le l'entrepreneur qui est
en fait un tout petit entrepreneur
l'entreprise l'entreprise moyenne en
france et c'est une toute petite
entreprise avec un ou deux salariés et
c'est très petites entreprises sont les
plus nombreux sur le territoire donc à
elles n'ont pas forcément accès à ce à
toute cette formation l'apprentissage
donc elle ne voit pas vraiment l'utilité
d'une chambre de commerce alors que
l'utilité de la chambre de commerce
c'est à travers effectivement l'ensemble
des politiques économiques le
développement de tiers lieux les
l'aménagement les infrastructures le
développement des logements et le chant
de
le chant est très très vague c'est une
course qui concourt à l'attractivité
d'un territoire au développement
économique et au développement des
emplois à travers notamment la formation
professionnelle là il ya parfois eu des
des conflits entre justement les
politiques régionales et piles et des
chambres de commerce pour savoir qui
était qui devait mener les politiques
économiques et la finance absolument et
vous vous dites voilà il faut se
rapprocher maintenant des pouvoirs
publics pour mener une vraie politique
économique dans un territoire
concrètement ça veut dire quoi je dirais
c'est
on a si on prend le cas des yvelines on
à 262 communes on a cinq grands
territoires chacun chacune chacune des
communes chaque interco chaque
territoire développe ses propres
dispositifs pour ses ressortissants pour
ces pour ses habitants je pense que la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie doit
être un peu la courroie de transmission
de tout ça doit un peu fédérer avoir un
rôle fédérateur ce qu'elle fait à
travers l'animation d'un certain nombre
de réseaux dans le territoire et jeu il
faut il faut retrouver un peu il faut
que cette chambre devienne la maison de
tous les entrepreneurs en lien avec tous
les territoires c'est à dire avec tous
les acteurs politiques locaux esquissé
un peu distendues ces derniers temps
pour des histoires de financement sont
deux histoires de d'autonomie
d'autonomie de des chambres de commerce
et d'industrie mais là je pense qu'on
l'a on est dans un dans un une un moment
notre d'autres si de notre histoire où
là il faut vous travaillez ensemble et
c'est ce qu'on a laissé la façon dont on
a gagné finalement cette élection en
rassemblant près de 180 organisations
professionnelles unions de commerçants
syndicat du territoire donc faut
continuer ça avec les collectivités qui
sont les premiers donneurs d'ordre des
projets développement économique vous
avez une vision d'ensemble de ce que
l'entrepreneuriat il ya une formidable
évolution on va y revenir peuvent quand
on voit pas de portage salarial et de
votre entreprise notamment mais une
formidable évolution avec beaucoup de
naissance de l'entreprise individuelle
d'entreprise
les entreprises unipersonnelles trois
fois
il y d'abord vous vous occupez touche
mais les problèmes sont pas les mêmes
des très grandes entreprises aussi dans
les yvelines pour les très grandes
entreprises et pour les des entreprises
qui ont une seule personne par exemple
c'est la particularité je crois de notre
département où on a historiquement un
des tissus industriels les plus
développés de france et de la région
avec de très grandes entreprises
industrielles qui en pleine transition
écologique l'est de la fin du moteur
thermique annoncé
les nouvelles les les énergies
alternatives vont devoir se réinventer
en termes de mobilité en termes de
décarbonation en terme de
deux nouveaux usages et puis d'un autre
côté on moi j'ai découvert pendant
pendant cette campagne qu'on l'avait
dans le territoire 83000 auto
entrepreneurs tous les petites
entreprises j'ai lu cinq ans il y avait
55 bis d'entreprise que vouliez doublé
5000 entrepreneurs 106 1000
entreprises et établissements parce
qu'on a un grand nombre d'entreprises en
fait si on prend des grandes enseignes
qui ne sont que les établissements dont
globalement meilleurs que moi je grossis
le trait en disant que c'est un peu plus
de cent mille entreprises avec des
entrepreneurs qui pour deux tiers
d'entre eux dans le département on a
fait un peu de statistiques ont au moins
deux entreprises d'accord donc on a
parlé d'eux voilà voilà et puis qu'on a
on a globalement on a un pour cent des
entreprises du département qui sont des
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
pour donner un peu le l'ordre de
grandeur donc effectivement il faut à la
fois pour cent voilà 1% c'est et puis
alors là si on parle si on parle du cac
40 on a un certain nombre de sièges
sociaux de très grandes entreprises là
on sait c'est une poignée d'entreprises
c'est 0 001 % des entreprises donc c'est
pour tout ça pour dire attendre nous
avons re dire que finalement le prisme
doit être tournée de mon point de vue
vers l'est vers les porteurs de projets
vers les créateurs vers les futures
entreprises parce que le challenge
pour les dix prochaines années on a des
chiffres intéressants on a déjà un quart
des français
qui veulent déménager donc ça c'est très
important et on a 90 % des métiers qui
vont être soi qui vont disparaître soit
qu'ils vont être profondément impactés
par les nouveaux usages notamment la
transition écologique numérique
dimension incroyable tous à ce que ce
que ça veut dire c'est on a vécu une
période noire de notre histoire ont
atteint cette pandémie qui a
complètement gelé notre activité mais
d'un autre côté c'est la plus belle
opportunité qu'on n'ait jamais eue en un
siècle de réinventer notre monde ce que
font ce que font étymologiquement
parlant les entrepreneurs et l'inter
sont sans faire de de donner de leçons
interp rehen d'airé saisir avec la main
maîtrisé et moi je dit généralement se
saisir se saisir des problèmes se saisir
des sujets pour réinventer et changer le
monde qui nous entoure
et c'est votre projet c'est de doubler
en effet le nombre d'entreprises
doublons dans les cinq ans et celle de
honda parce que globalement on est dans
une
dynamique de toute façon qui ceux qui
s'orientent de plus en plus on voit
qu'on a de plus en plus de demandeurs
d'emploi donc le chômage n'a jamais
cessé de croître au cours des 50
dernières années donc ça c'est un fait
et puis de l'autre on a un taux de
création d'entreprises qui est en forte
augmentation partout dans le monde en
france on a quand même un système qui
permet de préserver
à coup de deux subventions d'exonération
les emplois salariés il faut bien
comprendre que dans les dix prochaines
années
on va doubler le nombre d'indépendants
et d'entrepreneurs donc après il faut
certains disent que c'est peut-être la
fin du salariat qui se dévouent à lui le
foyer peut être plus long terme crise
mais c'est plutôt une opportunité
certains peuvent penser que c'est une
crainte quelle que soit cette chance
quelle que soit sa formation quel que
soit son niveau quel que soit son
origine sociale joue m fils d'ouvrier
je n'étais pas destiné à audrey à la
tête d'une entreprise de plusieurs
centaines de salariés donc voilà cessé
de dire que l'ascenseur social
fonctionne versées et l'entrepreneuriat
je pense ou être vraiment au coeur des
politiques publiques davantage que les
politiques de l'emploi
en même temps ils veulent un article du
parisien l'autre julien on n'a jamais
autant bossé en france dire que
un mot peut-être justement sur les
conséquences de la crise interne au
monde on a eu très peur non pas c'est
que ça a des conséquences terribles on
voit que finalement ça se passe plutôt
mieux que ce qu'on pouvait craindre que
l'emploi repart
vous quelle est votre vision vous êtes
plutôt optimiste là aussi sur ceux sur
ce point
évidemment ça repart avec ça repart
mieux puisqu'on a rattrapé en fait le
niveau d'avant crise donc là il ya un
fait les politiques publiques qui ont
été mises en place pendant la pandémie
ont des résultats bénéfiques sur
l'ensemble des entreprises et notamment
les très petites entreprises et
phénomène incroyable on n'a jamais créé
autant d'entreprises en l'espace d'un an
on en a créé près d'un million entre
mais 2020 et mai 2021 donc c'est dire
que non seulement effectivement il ya
une reprise mais on on peut aller bien
au delà si on accompagne ses créateurs
ce néo entrepreneurs ces néo
entrepreneurs
alors on va parler un peu de votre
parcours vous disiez vous donner dans un
quartier plutôt difficile vous êtes des
dans le val fourré je crois donc là je
dis ça vu grandi j'ai grandi aux elfes
vous avez grandi quels souvenirs vous
avez de 7,7 enfance comme ça alors moi
j'ai eu la chance de quand j'étais très
petit effectivement de de vivre et j'ai
fait toute ma scolarité d'ailleurs au
val fourré et puis entre le val fourré
et juste à côté bouin villans mantois
donc un tout petit village au vert à 10
km avec voilà 200 habitants des champs à
perte de vue donc c'est ces deux
facettes un peu
du territoire et deux facettes de la
france finalement les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville d'un côté avec
des taux de chômage qui monte à 60 %
notamment val fourré aujourd'hui donc là
il ya un gros travail à faire et puis de
l'autre
les déserts ruraux et des héros on a pu
de abois ville on a plus de on a plus de
commerçants et comment comment avec 7
cette opportunité qu'on a à travers
cette transition écologique et numérique
avec le digital a dit qu'à lisation
comment est-ce qu'on peut peut-être
recréer de l'activité recréer de
l'emploi danser dans ces deux zones un
peu un peu délaissée dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville comment on crée
de l'activité auprès de l'activité et
dans l'est dans les territoires ruraux
également avec des politiques qu'ils
soient qu'ils sont de kick donne
d'ailleurs d'aider des résultats
satisfaisants mais c'est vrai qu'il ya
un effort énorme affaire
vous avez ensuite et éducateurs
spécialisés vous avez fait des études de
sciences physiques et de sciences de
l'éducation je crois et je n'ai pas
l'impression chez vous qui a cette
volonté transmettre abbas et le
quelques petites entreprises didaxis
c'est l'art de transmettre en fait moi
je j'ai toujours vécu en fait moi le ma
plus grosse expérience c'est le milieu
associatif et j'ai toujours été lens est
dans cette dynamique de transmission
j'ai toujours été dans une dynamique
aussi de mentorat
d'accompagnement il se trouve que ma
première expérience entrepreneuriale
c'est au collège lorsque j'avais 11 ans
de me dire bah tiens il ya il ya plein
de choses à faire pourquoi est-ce qu'on
est ce qu on remettrait pas la
coopérative au coeur des projets
de l'école et puis voilà on part avec
une une poignée de avec une poignée de
gamins à l'époque et puis on créé voilà
ont créé un commerce et à la fin on l'a
quoi on a une vingtaine de vendeurs et
les fruits de ce qu'on gagne ça finance
les voyages de fin d'année de tous ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens de se les sur
les financer finalement l'entreprise
aujourd'hui et mon expérience entreprise
est née n'est pas éloigné de cette
première expérience que j'ai eu il ya un
peu plus de 30 ans parce que finalement
l'entreprise ce qu'on oublie souvent on
la pointe du doigt lorsque ça ne va pas
mais on oublie que sa mission première
est une mission sociale parce qu'elle
crée les emplois elle crée de l'activité
elle crée de la richesse des territoires
est qui et qui se serait parti après
alors il se trouve que voilà vouliez
être indépendante dans la façon
d'exercer votre métier que ça n'existait
pas à l'époque et donc vous retrouver au
chômage
et en 2004 vous êtes chômage et vous
décidé de fonder cette entreprise qui va
s'appeler didaxis et qui est un succès
considérable aujourd'hui mais comment on
fait quand on dit on vire du val fourré
on est au chômage et comment on fait
pour créer une entreprise
que trouvez défaut vous trouvez des
alors aujourd'hui non parce que tout le
monde me tout le monde de faire les
porte bien évidemment au départ je veux
voir des banques on me dit en plus
j'étais en domiciliation en un centre
d'affaires ce que j'ai pas les moyens
j'ai démarré avec 1000 euros en vente ou
les fonds de tiroir donc j'avais aucun
réseau je connaissais personne je vais
aucun entrepreneur ma famille enfin je
sais pour dire que c'était pas simple et
les banques ont fermé vont fermer ont
fermé les portes aujourd'hui bon ce sont
les mêmes qui nous déroule le tapis
rouge qui se déroule le tapis rouge qui
veulent financer
des rachats à l'international
développement et la croissance externe à
l'époque c'était plus compliqué donc
c'est bon et ce sont des étapes
finalement l'entrepreneur c'est
quelqu'un qui se nourrit de ses échecs
et qui je trouve rebondi d'échec en
échec et je veux dire aujourd'hui j'en
suis à une étape de la création de
l'activité oui c'est un fait qui ont
fait des succès passés didaxis c'est
quoi cette sauce avery aujourd'hui un
peu plus de 700 un peu plus 700 salariés
et 25 c 25 sociétés 25 700 équivalents
temps plein avec quelques en fait c'est
2500 personnes mais qu' un certain
nombre travail à mi temps là les
activités de services à la personne des
activités de bâtiment on a on accompagne
des personnes en reconversion notamment
des personnes des seniors des gens qui
conte reconverti sur un sur un nouveau
métier pour une deuxième partie de
carrière
donc voilà
[Musique]
c'est une entreprise de portage salarial
alors peut-être que les gens ne savent
pas exactement ce que c'est le très
confidentiel finalement le partage
mariale si on simplifie en fait c'est un
statut d'indépendant et de salariés on
est vraiment dans les nouvelles formes
de travail salarié les gens là ce sont
des professionnels qu'on qualifie d'
autonome qui bénéficie d'un contrat de
travail et qui ont autonomie dans le
développement de leur clientèle ce sont
des indépendants qui ont un statut de
salarié qui ont une fiche de paie donc
ils n'ont plus les problèmes pour se
loger pour pour les crédits à la
consommation etc voilà on a
aussi une ovation c'est incroyable ça
c'est à dire que de de concilier à la
fois le salarié à la production du
salariat et l'indépendance c'est ça
votre en 2004 on est quoi on est une
dizaine d'acteurs c'est totalement
illégal parce qu'on est en plein on est
en plein marchandage de main d'oeuvre et
aujourd'hui c'est un développement qui a
encouragé c'est par le gouvernement par
le ministère du travail une convention
collective a été mise en oeuvre pour
vraiment accompagner cette
transformation du monde du travail donc
là on est vraiment si on prend plus
regardent de haut dans l'accompagnement
des politiques publiques de l'emploi
donc c'est pas c'est pas juste un un
business c'est bien au delà de ça laisse
glisser quasiment un million un million
de français qui ont utilisé ce
dispositif sur les 15 dernières quinze
dernières années pour rebondir donc
c'est aussi ce qui m'a inspiré pour
donner davantage de protections aux
indépendants aujourd'hui c'est aux
travailleurs de plateformes de dire mais
je ne peux pas imaginer parce qu'ils
disent oui voila je commence à imaginer
les systèmes un peu hybride ont
finalement lorsqu'on a aucun filet on
bénéficierait quand même d'une
protection sociale en cas de déconfiture
alors vous parlez de transmission vous
avez écrit plusieurs livres aux éditions
du cherche midi à la plupart le premier
c'était justement tous indépendants en
2017 et qui était justement sur sur
votre expérience et l'idée que le
travail était en train de changer
justement le monde de l'entreprise aussi
ensuite il start-up république c'est ça
alors c'est avec la chanson de la france
a la chance d'avoir d'avoir des start-up
heures de gdi et qui dégueule il ya
évidemment la création de les start up
mais aussi une nouvelle façon de vivre
l'entreprise j'ai l'impression ça se
passe pas tout à fait pareil dans des
start-up que dans les entreprises
traditionnelles pour les supports un
mouroir y est notamment dans les
yvelines avec le laitière lieu qui se
développe on voit tous ces jeunes
entrepreneurs qui fédère aussi des
experts un peu plus expérimenté et qui
ont les façons de travailler des façons
de gérer leurs activités de d'animer
leur réunion totalement différente de ce
qu'on trouve dans les entreprises
traditionnelles
troisième c'était changer de job changer
de vie pendant le confinement et pendant
ce temps là vous parlez d'ailleurs dos
livre de de l'importance de trouver un
mentor oui
quelqu'un qui puisse vous conseillez
quoi faut pas être seul c'est vrai que
ce qui ce qui revient le plus souvent
c'est la solitude
alors de l'entrepreneur ou de la
personne en reconversion et on a
aujourd'hui 90% des salariés
qui sont pas
c'est une étude récente qui ne se
sentent pas bien là où il semblait
heureux au travail oui on serait aussi
devenir de la question est-ce que je
peux changer mais moi ce qu'elle risque
je vends cette question que je pose dans
des entretiens de recrutement
en dehors de je leur dis souvent mais en
dehors de cet entretien si vous aviez le
choix que feriez vous et bien souvent
les réponses sont des aux antipodes des
jeux je partirai en afrique dans une ong
j'ai rêvé de traverser l'atlantique
à voile etc
allez-y foncez réaliser vos rêves
libérez votre talent et ses deux sets
c'est de cette richesse que qu'on peut
créer de l'activité qu'on peut créer des
entreprises qu'on peut créer de belles
carrières de beaux parcours plutôt que
lier pour changer de nom mais
globalement aujourd'hui fin déjà les
créateurs historiquement il ya une
dizaine d'années les créateurs
d'entreprise c'était délicat car des
gens qui avaient au moins une
cinquantaine d'années des gens un peu
expert mais surtout des gens qui ne
trouvaient plus de plage ou dans le
monde de l'entreprise il ya aussi
et aujourd'hui bah on a des créateurs
qui sont de plus en plus jeune que l'âge
l'âge moyen des créateurs aujourd'hui a
baissé de quasiment 12 ans en l'espace
de quinze ans tout cela se précipite sur
le verre de livres qui s'appelait serait
en outre tous entrepreneurs
dit d'ailleurs il ya 15 millions de
français qui chercheraient et qu'il
faudrait créer une entreprise
globalement il ya 15 millions d'actifs
globalement c'est 50% des actifs voilà
on a à peu près à peu près 15 millions
de français qui ont envie sérieusement
de créer de créer leur entreprise en
tout cas de créer leur activité je
dirais parce qu'aujourd'hui on a quand
même une part très importante à
l'économie sociale et solidaire dans
lesquels on a en fait de nouvelles aussi
de nouvelles formes d'entreprises
étaient nouvelle fait d'effort une
entreprise associative coopérative est
d'ailleurs dans certains pays étrangers
en fait les associations sont des
entreprises sans capitaux par exemple
concret créer une activité créer une
entreprise c'est pas que créer une
entreprise au sens où longtemps ça peut
être aussi créé une association qui a
pour vocation
d'avoir un impact sur notre
environnement sur l'emploi sur le climat
sûr et donc dans les allées dans les
yvelines on est super bien lotis on a
pas mal de ces on a des des applications
comme yucca qu'on utilise tous le coeur
artificiel
le clou il richesse
aéronautique le spatial vous vous rendez
compte un peu la richesse de diversité
des entreprises qu'on a même si le
constat dans tous entrepreneurs c'est
souvent j'ai pas là j'ai pas d'idée
c'est souvent ce qui revient je n'ai pas
la bonne idée et c'est vous dire il n'y
a pas besoin d'avoir une bonne idée on
manque de 200000 codeurs de notre pays
deux cent mille personnes pour coder les
applications 107 ses terres du du sans
contact qu'on avait prouvé qu'on vit
depuis maintenant un an et demi donc il
ya ce sujet là et codeurs aujourd'hui on
peut être codeurs en cinq semaines oui
donc voilà égales par l'ingénieur
associatif
et et là ça peut s'exercer de manière
indépendante
savons peut gagner correctement sa gré
on a plein d'autres métiers l'industrie
du caire tout le poulet tous les soins à
domicile
c'est pareil c'est un peu plus de cinq
cent mille créations d'emplois
indépendants qui peuvent être créées là
sous cinq ans voyez donc on a vraiment
énormément d'opportunités puis tous les
métiers manuels qui ont quasiment
disparu l'artisanat l'art with anna se
meurt il ya des emplois
deux peuvent
envoyer à tous entrepreneurs si vous
avez envie voilà de créer votre
entreprise enfin l'idée bas lisez disait
ce livre qui va vous vous aider un mot
pour terminer parce que malheureusement
le temps
pour terminer il ya la compagne
électorale a qui commence et
présidentielle qui commence à se lancer
ça vous passionne ça vous laisse
indifférent ou pensez que c'est
important pour les chefs d'entreprise de
savoir qui va gagner au fond que c'est
ce qui est intéressant en tout cas
c'est que
des politiques publiques ont été
largement mobilisée ces cinq dernières
années en faveur des entreprises et de
l'entrepreneuriat bon ça c'est un
premier loin et puis d'autre part on
s'aperçoit que il n'ya pas un seul
candidat notamment hier à villepinte je
crois qu'ils ne ne fait l'impasse sur
les sujets économiques et
entrepreneuriat donc c'est dire qu'en
tout cas
l'entrepreneur et l'entreprise devient
quand même un sujet de deux premières
places
avant l'avait l'emploi on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui que l'emploi ça passe par
les entreprises parce que si on détruit
les entreprises il falloir ont recréé et
donc voilà falloir avoir des candidats
qui s'intéresse à la façon dont ça
fonctionne merci beaucoup guillaume
cairou et donc voilà vous êtes le
nouveau président de chambre de commerce
et d'industrie des îles disent merci
[Musique]